[Music]
do you guys know who michelle
nichols is nob i know michelle my belle
what who let me show my made up name
michelle my bear
[Laughter]
i think he's singing a song are you
seeing this live beatles
one more time joe bing
okay you're supposed to know it
okay this has nothing to do with that
uh michelle nichols who broke barriers
for black women in hollywood when she
played lieutenant ohora on the original
star trek tv series has died at the age
of 89.
wait her name was lieutenant ahora ahora
yeah you don't know star trek no
remember her or her
yeah also played by zoe saldana and the
muslim star the reboot it just sounds
like a funny name are you a star trek
fan i am well with you guys
not really the tv shows i watched some
because i had to because there's nothing
else on tv during that time nice what a
fan i was randomly one of those like i'd
rather star wars type [ __ ] but the new
star trek movies were sick
she in next generation was she and she
was in og the og oh wow the next
enterprise is that what it's called
with patrick i was too stupid to
understand the original series t-o-s is
what they call it star trek the most
boring show on the planet no [ __ ] you
bart it's a good show dude how old were
you guys because
i think we're we're older we're we're
older right but then like but she's part
of she was part of pop culture right you
guys always say you're older like you're
[ __ ] from 14th century no no but i
need to [ __ ] chill those critical
years though like it made me not get
into dragon ball pokemon or like that's
because you're a loser and you were in
the loser's stuff because you were
robbing houses yeah you were just doing
dumb [ __ ] so my point is i was older but
i didn't understand star trek the way
that you guys did because i was [ __ ]
dumb bro yeah see that's a different
excuse
it's not like i was born no that's
because i'm dumb therefore star trek is
entertaining though you just have to i
was honestly i was too dumb to
understand wait so so that's what my
question is when did you get into star
trek because when i was a kid i was like
these guys talk too much yeah when are
they gonna [ __ ] like go to space and
so it depends on what your entry was so
my father was big on star trek the next
generation
so that was my first uh that was the 90s
right that's different
he has like he has a dad who like
understands english and stuff so that's
why there's an easier way to go
so like patrick stewart john luke picard
like all that oh that one that was a
really boring bald guy
boring whenever yeah okay awesome great
thanks bart so nichelle was part of the
original series which came before next
generation right so next generation was
like the next iteration because they
actually done they did like six movies
with the original series cast like 20
like is that what shadow years yeah
we're shatner 20 years after the
original series air which was like
1966 to 1969
um and then they did like 20 years of
movies and then they rebooted it with
the next generation they did movies with
those cats right and they actually
blended the two the movie called
generations which is like captain kirk
shatner and like um patrick stewart
i'm sorry
okay hey well if you want to sneeze at
this
the whole point of what i'm trying to
explain to you guys is
the the actual impact that nichelle nick
nichols had on pop culture
because she was a black woman in the
1960s who was depicting a science
officer or i'm sorry a communications
officer on on the enterprise oh that was
like oh she's black and she's a woman
and she's doing science no like it was
like a big it was it was a lot of things
right so so one of the one of the
biggest things that she did
as a first
was she wasn't
in need of anybody on tv right she
wasn't like anybody's like house made or
anything like that okay yeah all the
time she was like a part of the ship she
was part of the crew she was on the
bridge it's like a big deal like if
you're on the bridge like you're she's
like an equal yeah yeah and that's
awesome kisses captain kirk in an
episode that they aired
um which was the first interracial
on-screen kiss for really
what
yeah so wait what so her and shatner
kissed
so this was in the 60s in the 60s
because i think interracial marriage was
still illegal until the 60s who knows
because he was looking at vintage porn
at the time
he was looking for interracial vintage
for the japanese guy on this one too the
gay guy he's really famous about sulu
yeah you're talking about the georgia
kai george it's the same it's the same
era yeah yeah but leonard leonard is on
the show okay okay okay oh geez okay
well one of the coolest things about
this right so so um
you know she did that scene with
um shatner
and the network are they um they they
were like hey can we do one with the
kiss and one without the kiss just in
case and then she wrote in her book
she's like we both
just [ __ ] up on every on the other
takes so that they had to use the kiss
on purpose
yeah because they wanted that to be out
there so how do you [ __ ] up on a take
where you're not supposed to kiss
no they they were given dialogue and
they kept on [ __ ] it up
that's tight
oh we can't use that actually we can't
use that that's probably what it was
um so yeah
misha my ba bing bang bang
no that's not the line
uh so she was you know she was a big
part of i mean
star trek doesn't exist like as we all
know it without her being involved
because like uhura was a huge manchester
character she was she was she got kind
of you know sidebarred a lot in the
movies because in the movies they they
did all kinds of they only have a
limited amount of time to push the plot
too for sure but she um she remembers uh
a moment so she had done like one season
of star trek right this is in 66 and she
remembers she was going to quit the show
she was like yeah i'm an actress i just
want to do a bunch of different stuff i
don't want to get type cast and pigeon
holed into one part right and then she's
at a party with martin luther king jr no
way
and he was a big fan of her
uh of star trek wow big fan of like what
it said right because because what you
[ __ ] don't know about star trek
and you guys are like oh it's so
dialogue heavy so boring it was trying
to show a version of us where a race
doesn't matter and like we're all in the
future and all that stuff is just melted
away and we're all focused on
progressing mankind i got that from
beverly hillbillies
you don't like beverly hills did you do
that dude
that girl was so hot
how did you do that bart has future tech
it was at the same time i don't know
what you're talking about how you got
there but you never watched beverly
hills you saw diversity in beverly
hillbillies well it's all
he's like they're hillbillies but they
live in hollywood
that's how i got there
no so martin luther king was like hey um
she told him i'm not gonna return for a
second season and he was like
he was like you have you cannot do that
you
oh wow
you changed the face of tv forever and
that's why and therefore you've changed
the minds of people in the culture
you cannot leave and she said that was a
lightning bolt in her life and it made
her stay and that like propelled her
career so like she was on that series
for like the next four years and then
she ended up doing all the movies and
like it just became more normal right
and that was what was cool about it
is that why people on screen
is so important to like i guess the
general
like conception or perspective of the
world right because like for me because
like in culture because for me it's like
what is more important to me is what i
see in real life
right so like let's say let's say like
uh like
leading man asian dude with like i don't
know white chick or something it seems
so crazy to see that on screen right but
then for me i'm like what do you mean
i've seen a lot of my friends are in
interracial relationships so i'm like to
me that's not a big deal
um but it feels like like when they see
that on screen then it's like finally
stamped in or something well at the time
most people i think interracial
relationships were illegal not only
illegal but shunned upon yeah so then
when they do it on screen
no one's really seen it in real life
also
at the risk of complimenting you you're
like a needle mover whereas a lot of
people why risk why are we at risk
because i just don't like to do that
um like in terms of like you're
an influencer so you're already doing
things you're around people that are
influencing others whereas other people
who don't influence other people who get
influence they do need those things they
do need to see those things in order to
validate or affirm like their own
existence in the space you know what i'm
saying i see yeah that's like in the
beginning people will be like oh my god
but why you so buff and it's like man
you small compared to these other asian
guys now
because it was a trend set to be a fit
big little asian guy
because a lot of people didn't believe
that can happen yeah for real one of the
craziest things about this too i don't
know about the illegal thing i don't i
don't i literally don't know i think
interracial was illegal till the 60s but
yeah but they didn't so lucy lucille
ball and rick ricardo who didn't predate
this
huh
lucy and ricky it was yeah it was it was
a weird gray area because he's not black
and they say interracial i think they
really mean black 1951 they did predate
this for sure but then that was
different because it's cuban and what we
do but we also do this thing too where
we like
just completely write off a whole
like timeline as like they were all this
way but like there was um
like people expected that there would be
backlash for this but the star trek
creators said they never got more mail
it was all positive like at the time
they said they never got more mail in
their life and that was like america
right they were all like being like yo
this is amazing that you guys did this
so that's rad that's really cool but
that's part of the the the thing about
star trek that i love about star trek is
that it does it always is future forward
it's always looking at like what we
could be and like it melts away all the
[ __ ] that we all do about each other
like the suppositions and all the like
oh i think about you this and the
stereotype about you is this and all
this [ __ ] that's cool i never thought of
it that way yeah i never knew star trek
was like that forward thinking or like
that intentional with all the people
that they had that was the that was the
thing about gene roddenberry at the time
which was awesome duncan on star trek
well it's because beverly hillbilly is
hard to compare merit dude oh she was so
hot imagine if they just didn't get
letters because all the haters are like
man if i could write and read i'd be
sending a pretty angry letter
they couldn't even write a read
[Laughter]
that makes me want to watch star trek i
like gilligan's island too oh that was
so good
that was my star trek
[Music]
[Music]
you